so when uh when the movie was coming out
I I actually happened to run into Nancy
Reagan and I said I got this movie
coming out said let's screen it so we
sent it to Camp David and that following
week reikan comes into the meeting of
his generals and says has anyone seen
this movie War games kid could start
World War III by accident and it really
got him thinking and and his generals
looked into it and said oh yeah it could
happen as it turns out that a lot of
even the current cyber security laws
that are on the books in the US
government sort of have their
foundation in that screening and in what
happened as a result of that um it it it
it was a real sort of case study in how
popular culture and story can actually
have an effect on policy because it
presents ideas in a way that can be
understood